It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And we've been talking here at the radio show recently about a certain genre of movie, which is the "making of" movie. A movie about the making of another film, usually a much more famous one. A classic is Hearts of Darkness, which is a "making of" documentary about the film Apocalypse Now, which has footage that the director Francis Ford Coppola's wife Eleanor shot at the time the movie was being filmed. Plus, incredibly, these recordings that she made of her husband without him knowing it, where he's talking about his self-doubt, his despair.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。最近我们在节目里一直在讨论一种电影类型，那就是“电影拍摄幕后”纪录片。这是一种关于另一部电影拍摄过程的电影，通常被记录的电影会更加出名。经典之作《黑暗之心：一部电影制作的启示》就是关于电影《现代启示录》的拍摄纪录片，其中包含了导演弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉的妻子埃莉诺在电影拍摄期间拍摄的素材。此外，令人难以置信的是，她还在丈夫不知情的情况下录下了他关于自我怀疑和绝望的谈话。
(SUBJECT) FRANCIS FORD
弗朗西斯·福特
There are candid moments with the actors, Dennis Hopper, Laurence Fishburne, who's 14 years old when they were making that film.
片中还有演员们私下的坦诚时刻，比如丹尼斯·霍珀，还有拍摄那部电影时年仅14岁的劳伦斯·菲什伯恩。
[ACTOR'S INDISTINCT CHATTER]
[演员含糊的交谈声]
Martin Sheen, who plays the main character, has a heart attack when they're there, at 36. Marlon Brando, the film's most expensive star. At some point, Coppola realizes that Brando has not read the book that the movie is based on, Heart of Darkness. So he does not get who his character is. And he's being paid $1 million a week.
饰演主角的马丁·辛在拍摄期间突发心脏病，当时他才36岁。马龙·白兰度是片中最昂贵的明星。科波拉在某个时刻意识到，白兰度根本没读过电影原著《黑暗之心》，所以他完全不理解自己饰演的角色是谁。而他当时的片酬是每周100万美元。
And all throughout, there are hints and glimpses of what's really happening in reality in the place that they're filming this movie. They're in the Philippines, where a US-supported autocrat is fighting a war against a communist insurgency. The movie's helicopters are US-made choppers flown by pilots in the Philippine military who keep getting pulled away to go back to the real war.
整个过程中，随处可见电影拍摄地现实状况的端倪。他们当时身处菲律宾，那里一位受美国支持的独裁者正在与共产主义叛军作战。电影中的直升机是美制机型，由菲律宾军方的飞行员驾驶，他们经常被抽调走，回到真正的战场去。
(SUBJECT) FRANCIS FORD
弗朗西斯·福特
The film Apocalypse Now is about Vietnam, but it's a big, mythic version of Vietnam, full of larger-than-life characters. The "making of" film reveals the normal-sized people building this grand cathedral, brick by brick. You see the ridiculous lengths everybody had to go through to create their pretend war and their fake, impossible Vietnam. Which brings me to today's radio show.
电影《现代启示录》讲的是越南战争，但那是一个宏大、神话般的越南，充满了超越常人的角色。而这部拍摄纪录片揭示了那些平凡的人是如何一块砖一块砖地建造这座宏伟教堂的。你看到了每个人为了创造他们那虚构的战争和那个虚假的、不可能的越南所付出的荒谬代价。这就引出了今天的话题。
Today's show is a "making of" of a different kind. It's people creating a picture of a place and a war that's happening there. And that place is Portland, Oregon. We're going to talk about Portland as a concept, what the city has come to mean in this political moment. Back in September, you may remember, President Trump declared on Truth Social that he was going to send troops into what he called "war-ravaged Portland" to protect ICE facilities there that were, quote, "under siege from attack by Antifa." Portland came to his attention, he said, by chance.
今天的节目是另一种形式的“幕后”。人们正在为一个正在发生的地点和战争构建某种图景。那个地点就是俄勒冈州波特兰市。我们将讨论作为一种概念的波特兰，以及这座城市在这个政治时刻所代表的意义。可能你还记得，去年九月，特朗普总统在“真实社交”平台上宣布，他要派遣军队前往他所谓的“饱受战争蹂躏的波特兰”，以保护那里“遭到反法西斯主义者（Antifa）围攻”的移民及海关执法局（ICE）设施。他说，波特兰是偶然进入他视野的。
That was not on my list, Portland, but when I watched television last night, this has been going on.
那本来不在我的名单上，波特兰，但当我昨晚看电视时，这种情况一直在发生。
Protesters had actually been outside the ICE facility since June, but Fox News, the night before, had run a story about Portland. And one thing about Fox's coverage, including that story, is that Fox's coverage includes lots of footage of protesters that is not filmed by professional TV news crews, but by the real auteurs behind the right wing's idea of what Portland is.
示威者其实从六月份起就一直在ICE设施外抗议，但福克斯新闻前一天晚上播出了一篇关于波特兰的报道。福克斯报道的一个特点，包括那篇报道在内，就是包含了大量示威者的视频，这些视频并非由专业的电视新闻摄制组拍摄，而是由那些在右翼眼中定义波特兰的真正“作者”们拍摄的。
These are right-wing citizen journalists who've been there at the protests, covering them more than anybody, especially live streamers who were there. These are people who believe in Trump, believe in ICE, who streamed from the Portland protests, saying that their lefty local government was soft on the protesters, letting Antifa run amok. Live streaming on YouTube and X.
这些人是右翼公民记者，他们一直身处抗议现场，比任何人都报道得更频繁，特别是那些在那里进行直播的人。这些人信仰特朗普，支持ICE，他们在波特兰抗议现场直播，声称当地的左翼政府对示威者软弱无力，任由反法西斯主义者胡作非为。他们在YouTube和X上进行直播。
All these people right here are the Antifa of Portland, all in black.
就在这里的所有人都是波特兰的反法西斯主义者，全都穿着黑衣服。
You come back, I'm going to fucking smoke you, dude.
你再敢回来，老子绝对崩了你，伙计。
Really?
真的吗？
Yes.
是的。
Some of the citizen journalists became regular guests on Fox, talking about this.
一些公民记者成为了福克斯新闻的常客，讨论这个问题。
(SUBJECT) FOX NEWS
福克斯新闻
It's a complete lie. There's lots of violence going on. I mean, these people are very dangerous, and they're unhinged. Just the other night--
这完全是谎言。这里发生了很多暴力事件。我的意思是，这些人非常危险，而且精神失常。就在前天晚上——
And a week and a half after the president declared Portland to be war-ravaged and under siege, he invited these streamers to the White House for a roundtable on Antifa. It was remarkable.
在总统宣布波特兰饱受战争蹂躏并处于被围攻状态一周半后，他邀请这些直播者到白宫参加关于反法西斯主义者的圆桌会议。这很了不起。
At least three of these courageous journalists have personally been victims of Antifa attacks
至少有三位勇敢的记者亲身遭受了反法西斯主义者的袭击。
Trump sat at the center of a U-shaped table with about a dozen of these reporters and streamers for an hour and a half. And flanking Trump at the table on his immediate left and right was the full political and law enforcement firepower of the federal government. Kristi Noem, head of the Department of Homeland Security, head of the FBI, Kash Patel, Attorney General Pam Bondi, Secretary of State Marco Rubio.
特朗普坐在U型桌的中央，周围有大约十几名记者和直播者，会议持续了一个半小时。坐在特朗普左右两边的是联邦政府全部的政治和执法力量。国土安全部部长克里斯蒂·诺姆、联邦调查局局长、卡什·帕特尔、司法部长帕姆·邦迪、国务卿马尔科·卢比奥。
After the president's opening remarks, Kristi Noem, head of DHS, fresh off the plane from Portland herself, talked directly to the streamers.
在总统开场致辞后，刚从波特兰飞抵的国土安全部部长克里斯蒂·诺姆直接对直播者们发表了讲话。
I want to thank the new journalists here today for telling their stories and for being able and willing to go to the streets and to cover what's happening here in America. Many times, the legacy media has looked the other way, refused to tell the stories and how this network of Antifa is just as sophisticated as MS-13, as TDA, as ISIS, as Hezbollah, as Hamas, as all of them.
我要感谢今天在场的这些新晋记者，感谢你们讲述自己的故事，感谢你们愿意走到街头，报道美国正在发生的事情。很多时候，传统媒体选择视而不见，拒绝讲述这些故事，而这个反法西斯主义者网络和MS-13、TDA、ISIS、真主党、哈马斯一样复杂，和他们是一丘之貉。
When the streamers spoke, it was in apocalyptic terms about Antifa, this supposed global network of anti-government anti-fascists. Streamers talked not just about being personally assaulted by Antifa protesters, but putting their lives on the line every day. One streamer said that she genuinely believed that if the president had not declared war on Antifa, people at this table would have been killed in Portland. Here's one of the best known citizen journalists covering Portland, Nick Sortor. He's been on Fox a bunch.
当直播者发言时，他们用世界末日般的词汇来形容反法西斯主义者这个所谓的反政府、反法西斯全球网络。直播者谈论的不仅是被示威者亲自攻击，还包括他们每天冒着生命危险进行报道。一位直播者说，她真诚地相信，如果总统没有宣布向反法西斯主义者开战，桌子上的这些人早就死在波特兰了。这是报道波特兰最知名的公民记者之一，尼克·索托尔。他多次上过福克斯新闻。
Frankly, the cities and police departments are cooperating with Antifa, such as Portland. It's sickening. I've seen it firsthand, obviously. And President Trump, you mentioned that flag. Remember, you put out a Truth right after I--
坦率地说，像波特兰这样的城市和警察部门正在与反法西斯主义者合作。这令人作呕。显然，我亲眼目睹了这一点。特朗普总统，你提到了那面旗帜。记得吗，就在我之后，你发布了一条“真实”……
That's right, I saw that.
没错，我看到了。
--took this flag from that man that was burning it in the street.
……从那个在街上焚烧旗帜的人手中夺过了这面旗帜。
I saw. Do you know who he is?
我看到了。你知道他是谁吗？
Oh, yeah. I know exactly who it is.
噢，是的。我非常清楚他是谁。
So why don't you give it to Pam? Give it to the attorney general and--
那你为什么不把它交给帕姆？交给司法部长，然后——
Mm.
嗯。
--let's start prosecutions.
——让我们开始起诉吧。
Attorney General Pam Bondi pipes in at that point to say she's already started an investigation.
司法部长帕姆·邦迪此时插话称，她已经开始调查了。
The purpose of all this, the point the administration was making with this event, was that in Portland, these streamers and citizen journalists were proving that the threat to America from Antifa is real and that a massive, nationwide hunt was called for. And this didn't just mean sending troops into American cities like Portland. It also meant treating Antifa as a domestic terror organization.
这一切的目的，行政当局通过这次活动想要表达的观点是：在波特兰，这些直播者和公民记者证明了反法西斯主义者对美国的威胁是真实存在的，并且需要进行一场大规模的全国性搜捕。这不仅意味着向波特兰这样的美国城市派遣军队，还意味着将反法西斯主义者视为国内恐怖组织。
The president had just named it that, and he ordered the National Joint Terrorism Task Force to create a national strategy to investigate and prosecute them with the FBI, the Justice Department, and other agencies, and to go after left-wing groups that it says are funding political violence. The speaker at this roundtable named some of them, like George Soros's Open Society Foundations. Organizations, who, of course, deny doing any such thing.
总统刚刚将其定性为恐怖组织，并下令全国联合反恐特遣部队与联邦调查局、司法部和其他机构制定全国战略，以调查和起诉他们，并追查那些被指控资助政治暴力的左翼团体。圆桌会议的发言人点名了其中一些组织，比如乔治·索罗斯的开放社会基金会。当然，这些组织否认有任何此类行为。
Since then, prosecutions are underway. Just this week, the FBI claimed to have disrupted a bomb plot in Southern California by anti-capitalist anarchists leftists with a group called the Turtle Island Liberation Front.
从那以后，起诉工作已经在进行中。就在本周，联邦调查局声称挫败了一起由一个名为“龟岛解放阵线”的反资本主义无政府主义左翼团体在南加州策划的炸弹阴谋。
To be clear, there is no question that there are violent leftist groups in our country, just like there are violent groups on the right. But there were already laws in place and law enforcement going after them. That's been one of the FBI's jobs forever.
需要明确的是，毫无疑问，我们的国家存在暴力的左翼团体，就像右翼也存在暴力团体一样。但法律早已存在，执法部门也一直在打击他们。这一直是联邦调查局的工作之一。
This is a new kind of crackdown, at a new scale, targeted only at political violence on the left. America is a big country. We all, from the president on down, rely on images and words from other people to understand what's going on elsewhere.
这是一场规模空前、只针对左翼政治暴力的新型镇压。美国是一个大国。从总统到平民，我们都依赖他人的影像和言论来了解其他地方正在发生什么。
And a vision of Portland, a movie about Portland as a place that's war ravaged, a hub for Antifa, ripe for military intervention, that story, promulgated by these streamers and citizen journalists, amplified on right wing TV and social media, that story is justification for all these law enforcement policies all over the country today, along with another story, of course. The assassination of Charlie Kirk.
关于波特兰的愿景，一部关于波特兰是一个饱受战争蹂躏、反法西斯主义者中心、成熟的军事干预目标的电影，那个由这些直播者和公民记者散布、在右翼电视和社交媒体上放大的故事，成为了今天全国所有执法政策的辩护理由，当然，还有另一个故事：查理·柯克的遇刺。
We wanted to see Portland for ourselves. We wanted to see the making of this story about what Portland is. The reality, the behind the scenes, turns out not just to be very different, but a lot more interesting than the thing that they're filming and the story that they're telling. Stay with us.
我们想亲眼看看波特兰。我们想看看关于波特兰的故事是如何被编造出来的。事实证明，幕后的真相不仅大相径庭，而且比他们拍摄的影片和讲述的故事要有趣得多。请留下来。
It's This American Life. Act One, Living the American Stream.
这里是《美国生活》。第一幕：活在美式直播中。
OK, so some basic facts before we head off to Portland. The way the president has described Portland, it might sound like an entire city under siege. But I think the first thing we need to clarify in this making of is that the entire conflict between protesters and police, the entire war, is happening on exactly one city block outside an ICE facility. Pretty much every day since June, protesters have been there opposing President Trump's immigration policies, like other protests around the country.
好的，在我们前往波特兰之前，先了解一些基本事实。按照总统对波特兰的描述，听起来整座城市都在围攻之下。但我认为在这次“幕后”调查中我们需要澄清的第一件事是，抗议者与警察之间的全部冲突，整场“战争”，其实都发生在移民及海关执法局（ICE）设施外面的那一个街区。从六月份起，几乎每天都有抗议者在那里反对特朗普总统的移民政策，就像全国各地的其他抗议活动一样。
The level of violence directed towards ICE is mostly blocking and slowing down their vehicles that are coming in and out, and small scuffles where federal police fire tear gas and pepper balls. There was one day in June when things flared up and were declared a riot. Protesters rammed a stop sign through a glass door, hit an ICE agent in the head with a rock. But that day was kind of a one off.
针对ICE的暴力程度大多是阻挡和延缓他们进出的车辆，以及联邦警察发射催泪瓦斯和胡椒球的小规模冲突。六月份有一天情况恶化，被宣布为暴乱。抗议者用停车标志撞碎了玻璃门，用石头击中了一名ICE特工的头部。但那一天算是孤立事件。
What it's been since then on any given day is anywhere from a half dozen to 200 people with music, chanting, bullhorns. During the daytime, it can have a kind of carnival performance art vibe, a street salsa class, people in inflatable frog costumes. There's a guy dressed like Bob Ross with an easel and a pallet, doing an oil painting of the ICE officers.
自那以后，每天的情况通常是六个人到两百人不等，伴随着音乐、口号和扩音器。白天，这可能有一种嘉年华表演艺术的氛围，有街头萨尔萨舞班，穿着充气青蛙服的人。有一个人打扮成鲍勃·罗斯，带着画架和调色板，正在为ICE警官画油画。
But then at night, it can get more confrontational with ICE. Sometimes protesters have burned American flags, graffitied outside the building, shot fireworks, and it gets confrontational between the protesters and the streamers who mix it up with them. Usually, there are anywhere between just a few streamers to maybe 30 or so. It gets really noisy and disruptive, and people living near the ICE facility complain to police about the noise.
但到了晚上，与ICE的对抗就会升级。有时抗议者会焚烧美国国旗，在建筑外乱涂乱画，燃放烟花，抗议者与那些挑衅他们的直播者之间也会产生冲突。通常现场有几名到大约30名直播者。现场变得非常吵闹和混乱，住在ICE设施附近的人们会向警察投诉噪音。
And when the streamers and citizen journalists say that the Portland police let all this happen, there's truth to that. They haven't stopped protesters from blocking sidewalks or surrounding and delaying ICE vehicles. They've allowed them to make noise. And a judge ruled that it was OK. That was the state of things when one of our producers, Zoe Chace, flew to Portland in October with another producer, Suzanne Gaber. Here's their story.
当直播者和公民记者说波特兰警察对此置之不理时，这确实有一定的事实依据。他们没有阻止抗议者封锁人行道，也没有阻止他们包围并延误ICE车辆。他们允许抗议者制造噪音。法官也裁定这是合法的。当我们的制作人佐伊·蔡斯与另一位制作人苏珊娜·加伯在十月份飞往波特兰时，情况就是这样。这是她们的故事。
When we got there, it had been about two weeks after the White House roundtable about Portland and Antifa. We got there after 10:00 on a Saturday night, late October. It was cold and rainy, but there are a lot of people out here wandering up and down the sidewalk.
当我们到达时，距离白宫关于波特兰和反法西斯主义者的圆桌会议已经过去了两周。我们在十月的一个周六晚上十点多到达。天气寒冷多雨，但人行道上来来往往有很多人。
[YELLING AND INDISTINCT CHATTER]
[叫喊声和模糊的交谈声]
And it's not grimy protesters dragging furry tails in the mud, dancing to "I Will Survive," or whatever I was picturing the campy Antifa Portland protest scene to be at this point. What we walk into is more like a Trump rally.
这并不是我此前想象中的那种反法西斯主义者抗议现场：污秽的抗议者拖着毛绒尾巴在泥地里跳着《我将生存》，或者其他什么奇装异服。我们走进的场景更像是一场特朗普集会。
[CROWD CHANTING, USA]
[人群高喊：美国！美国！]
I want you to picture, this is one long block with an ICE facility on one side and a tall apartment building on the other. Two long sidewalks, a big street in the middle that leads to The Old Spaghetti Factory. People are swarming both sides of the street, even late at night like this. There are a bunch of city cops in yellow slickers standing around, and all these people wandering around with their phones on long selfie sticks, talking into the phones and talking to each other.
我想请你想象一下，这是一个长街区，一边是ICE设施，另一边是一栋高大的公寓楼。两条长长的人行道，中间是一条通往老意大利面工厂的大街。即使是深夜，街道两旁也挤满了人。一群穿着黄色雨衣的城市警察站在周围，到处都是拿着长自拍杆、对着手机说话并互相交流的人。
Some of these people Suz and I recognize from the White House roundtable or from appearances on Fox. But mainly, I have no idea what I'm looking at. So we meet up with this one voluble streamer-- she calls herself an analyst-- Karlyn Borysenko. 128,000 subscribers on YouTube. And she's just pointing people out to us.
苏和我在现场认出了其中一些人在白宫圆桌会议上出现过，或者在福克斯新闻上露过面。但主要是，我完全不知道自己在看什么。所以我们遇到了这个健谈的直播者——她自称分析师——卡琳·博里森科。她在YouTube上有12.8万名订阅者。她一直在向我们指点人群。
The guy in the mask is a MAGA guy. The guy with the yellow hat right there is Antifa. The guy with the flag is Antifa.
那个戴口罩的是MAGA支持者。那个戴黄帽子的是反法西斯主义者。那个拿旗帜的也是反法西斯主义者。
Normally, Karlyn's streaming from home. She's kind of a commentator about the streamers. She'll have four different live videos up from four different live streamers. And it's like, camera one, no, camera two, while walking you through what or who to watch in the videos. Karlyn's a recovered lefty, now very much on the right. She considers herself an Antifa expert. She knows all these right-wing streamers and influencers, so she's a good person to follow around.
通常卡琳都在家里直播。她算是这些直播者的评论员。她会同时打开四个不同直播者的视频，像是在说：镜头一，不，镜头二，同时引导你观看视频里发生了什么或者谁是谁。卡琳曾经是左翼，现在坚定地站在右翼阵营。她认为自己是反法西斯主义者专家。她认识所有这些右翼直播者和网红，所以她是一个很好的向导。
Well JD Delay is there. He's got 1.6 million subscribers on YouTube. He's in the camo hat. And he's--
JD·德莱就在那儿。他在YouTube上有160万订阅者。他戴着迷彩帽，他正在——
I also spot Nick Sortor, 1.3 million followers on X. Cam Higby, 216,000 YouTube subscribers. They were both at the White House.
我也发现了尼克·索托尔，在X上有130万粉丝。卡姆·希格比，有21.6万YouTube订阅者。他们俩都在白宫开过会。
So a lot of people out here, it's kind of like they're just showing what's happening. And I think a lot of people out here are trying to get the best footage they can, regardless of what side they're on.
所以这里有很多人，他们似乎只是在展示正在发生的事情。我认为这里很多人都在努力获取他们能拍到的最好的素材，不管他们站在哪一边。
And what do they-- why? Do you know what I mean? Like, why? It's not as though it's not covered.
他们为什么这么做？你知道我什么意思吗？我是说，为什么？这又不是没有报道。
We're in a reality show right now. And you can see the reality show from that angle or that angle, or down there. I mean, I watch the live streams for hours and hours at a time on my YouTube channel when I'm at home. And you have all these different angles. You can skip around, see what's-- it's like-- you know what it's like? It's like the Big Brother house, where you can go in the kitchen or the bedroom just to spy on people. Same thing, except we're actually in it.
我们现在就像在真人秀里。你可以从那个角度或那个角度，或者那边看到这场真人秀。我是说，我在家时会在我的YouTube频道上连续几个小时观看这些直播。你有各种不同的角度。你可以跳来跳去，看发生了什么——它就像——你知道它像什么吗？就像《老大哥》的房子，你可以进厨房或卧室去窥探别人。是一样的，只是我们真的置身其中。
And it's addictive after a while. It's like you start-- there's characters in this story. There are people that are here all the time. So you get kind of endeared to some of them.
久而久之这会让人上瘾。这个故事里有角色，有些经常在这里出现的人。所以你会对其中一些人产生好感。
There's a reason so many right-wing streamers are in the same place at the same time the weekend that we're here. Since the White House roundtable, more and more of these streamers have been showing up here. Then recently, the anti-ICE protesters did this thing, which was put up a poster with a bunch of right-wing influencers' faces and handles and real names on it, saying, "don't take the bait." Meaning, don't give these guys content that they'll use as propaganda.
这就是为什么我们来的那个周末，那么多右翼直播者聚集在同一个地方的原因。自白宫圆桌会议以来，越来越多的这类直播者出现在这里。最近，反ICE抗议者搞了个名堂，贴了一张海报，上面印着一堆右翼网红的照片、账号名和真实姓名，写着“别上钩”。意思是，不要给这些家伙提供可以作为宣传内容的素材。
The streamers saw that and were like, OK, well, we're now all going to come at once. And we're going to make a lot of videos of you weirdos. And they're calling it Patriot Weekend.
直播者们看到后反应是：好吧，那我们现在要一起过去。我们要给你们这些怪人多拍点视频。他们把这称为“爱国周末”。
[INDISTINCT CHATTER]
[模糊的交谈声]
Some people are just standing around smoking and talking in the rain. And then these big circles form, out of what seems like nowhere, with people pushing and yelling like a playground fight--
有些人只是站在雨中抽烟聊天。然后这些大圈子似乎凭空形成，人们像操场斗殴一样推搡叫喊——
We ain't listening to that pedophile music, bro.
我们才不听那种恋童癖的音乐，兄弟。
--with all these other people jostling to film the fight in the middle of the circle, which is a yelling fight, to be clear, usually not a fist fight. And the people inside the circle are filming themselves being filmed and streaming that live to their followers. It's a circle of people and phones in a fight. I walk up to a group like this, try to push my way inside to see what's in the center. It looks like a dude in a bulletproof vest streaming a video of himself yelling at a guy with a Captain America shield.
——周围挤满了其他人，都在争先恐后地拍摄圈子中间的冲突，明确地说，那通常是叫骂式的打斗，而不是拳脚相向。圈子里的人拍着自己被拍摄的过程，并实时直播给他们的粉丝看。这是一个由人和手机组成的纠纷圈。我走进这样一群人，试图挤进去看中间发生了什么。看起来是一个穿着防弹背心的家伙正在直播自己对着一个拿着美国队长盾牌的人叫喊。
Stolen valor. We just proved it. It's disgusting. You're a liar. You're disgusting.
窃取荣耀。我们刚刚证明了。这真恶心。你是个骗子。你真恶心。
Apparently, thousands of people are watching this online right now. Karlyn and I elbow our way into a different crowd, but at the center nothing's happening. It seems like some fight has just ended and the streamers who were watching the fight start talking to each other about whatever that fight was about.
显然，现在有成千上万的人在网上观看这个直播。卡琳和我费力挤进另一个人群，但中间什么也没发生。似乎一场争吵刚结束，观看争吵的直播者们开始互相讨论刚才那件事的起因。
It's funny, now they're just doing a talk show of what just happened.
很有趣，他们现在正在把刚才发生的事情当脱口秀讲。
And that happens a lot. It's one of those things, again, it's a spectacle, right? There's something going on over here, but then you get to run over there. And maybe you get to provoke something over here. And you just never know what's going to happen, you know?
这种情况经常发生。这又是一回事，这就是场奇观，对吧？这边发生了什么，然后你就可以跑过去。也许你还能在那边挑起一点事端。你永远不知道会发生什么，你知道吗？
(SUBJECT) HIPPIE MAGA
嬉皮士MAGA
This is another rando chiming in. He's dressed like The Dude from The Big Lebowski, in a full robe with beads.
这是另一个凑热闹的家伙。他打扮得像《谋杀绿脚趾》里的“大人物”，穿着睡袍，带着珠串。
What's hippie MAGA?
什么是嬉皮士MAGA？
(SUBJECT) HIPPIE MAGA
嬉皮士MAGA
Who's The Crow?
谁是“乌鸦”？
(SUBJECT) HIPPIE MAGA
嬉皮士MAGA
Lots of handles flying around that I don't know. Karlyn looks around.
到处都在飞着我不知道的账号名。卡琳环顾四周。
Is there something people are waiting for now? What is everyone doing here, you know what I mean? It's 10:30, it's really cold and rainy.
大家现在是在等什么吗？每个人都在这里做什么，你知道我的意思吗？现在是十点半，又冷又下雨。
Yeah, well, you can see something's about to happen over there. It looks like a whole bunch of people are walking over there, so I don't know what's about to happen, but--
是的，好吧，你可以看到那边有些事要发生了。看起来很多人都在往那边走，所以我不知道要发生什么，但是——
Let's go see.
我们去看看。
Let's go see. Uh-oh. Everyone is just standing around with their phones.
去看看。噢，糟糕。每个人都只是拿着手机站在那儿。
Yeah, because it's like, if there's no-- if there's no fight, at some point, then there's nothing really to film, right?
是的，因为如果没有——如果没有打斗，在某个时刻就没什么可拍的了，对吧？
Yeah.
没错。
So at some point, something has to happen or there's nothing to see.
所以到了某个时刻，必须得发生点什么，否则就没什么可看的。
And you know what, I've kind of seen is it's--
你知道吗，我有点看出门道了，它是——
What you're--
你正在——
OK.
好的。
--putting out there, shame on you.
——发布那些东西，为你感到羞耻。
OK, bye, Pam.
好了，再见，帕姆。
Shame. Shame.
羞耻。羞耻。
Pam is a crazy person and she likes to come and yell at people.
帕姆是个疯子，她喜欢过来对着人叫喊。
You're not a psychologist.
你又不是心理学家。
Now someone comes up and starts scolding Karlyn. An older lady, infamous on X, The MAGA Granny. She went to prison for storming the Capitol on January 6th, but she's flipped. And now she's at every anti-Trump event you can think of. The right wingers call her Pam-tifa.
现在有人走过来开始教训卡琳。一位老年女士，在X上很有名，外号“MAGA老奶奶”。她因为1月6日冲击国会大厦而入狱，但她后来转向了。现在她出现在每一个你能想到的反特朗普活动中。右翼人士称她为“帕姆派反法西斯主义者”。
I don't even know what you're talking about. What are you upset about, Pam?
我甚至不知道你在说什么。帕姆，你因为什么而不满？
The big streamers can have tens of thousands of people watching them at one time, depending on what's going on. And they make real money from that, from paid subscribers. Fans tip them in real time. One streamer out here tonight, he got into this after streaming Fortnite. This pays more, he told us, being out here.
大直播者在同一时间可以有数万人观看，具体取决于正在发生什么。他们通过付费订阅赚取实实在在的钱。粉丝们会实时给他们打赏。今晚在这儿的一位直播者，他是在直播《堡垒之夜》后转行做这个的。他告诉我们，在这里直播比玩游戏赚得多。
But most streamers are more like Mike Ross, an out-of-town streamer. I followed him around for hours. He says he made money on crypto. So this is a hobby for him, not a job. Not yet, anyway. He's a very tall white guy in a big brown sweatshirt with a phone on a tripod, so he can film from really high up. He's a mental health advocate and a disabled veteran. He goes by MentallyIdaho on X. He's relatively new here, relatively few followers, 6,000. His vibe is high school football coach.
但大多数直播者更像迈克·罗斯，一个外地来的直播者。我跟着他走了几个小时。他说他在加密货币上赚了钱。所以这对他是爱好，不是工作。至少现在还不是。他是一个身材高大的白人，穿着一件大棕色运动衫，手机架在三脚架上，这样他可以从很高的地方拍摄。他是心理健康倡导者和残疾退伍军人。他在X上的账号是MentallyIdaho。他在这里比较新，粉丝比较少，只有6000个。他的风格像个高中橄榄球教练。
I flew back this weekend for Patriot Weekend. And just filming and live streaming and trying to get angles that other people don't get. Because I can do this and record what other people can't do.
这个周末我飞回来参加“爱国周末”。就是为了拍摄和直播，尝试获取别人拍不到的角度。因为我可以做到，并记录下别人做不到的东西。
Yeah, you have a big fish pole. You can get up really high.
是的，你有一根大鱼竿。你可以升得很高。
Yeah.
是的。
Plus you're tall.
而且你人很高。
Yeah, so I do stuff like that. What do you think of all the chaos?
是的，所以我做这类事。你觉得这些混乱怎么样？
[CROWD CHATTER]
[人群交谈声]
I just got here, honestly.
说实话，我刚到。
But you don't have an answer.
但你没有答案。
I don't have to answer, you dumb fuck.
我不需要回答，你这蠢货。
Mike said this thing about the way people talk to each other here, how mean and juvenile and graphic and vulgar it is. It's really like walking around inside social media, like we're in the comments section in real life. Remember, every person streaming here is not alone. They have this invisible mob surrounding them, sometimes animating them like a video game avatar. Mike's chat points him in various directions, saying go here, go there, collaborating and making things happen that turn into content.
迈克谈到了这里人们互相交谈的方式，那种刻薄、幼稚、充满图形和粗俗的语言。这真的就像走进了社交媒体内部，就像我们生活在现实版的评论区里。记住，这里直播的每一个人都不是孤身一人。他们身边有这群无形的暴民，有时像电子游戏化身一样驱使着他们。迈克的聊天室引导他去往不同的方向，叫他去这儿，去那儿，通过协作制造出变成内容的事件。
While I'm there with Mike, one of the streamers gets arrested, and his wife is really upset. Mike tells her they're going to get help from the chat.
当我和迈克在一起时，其中一名直播者被捕了，他的妻子非常难过。迈克告诉她，他们会从聊天室那里得到帮助。
Say it again?
再说一遍？
They said that he might have to pay bail to get out.
他们说他可能得交保释金才能出来。
OK. People want to know how to give money. So in a minute, we'll walk down to Tommy's chat and you can talk to both chats about that, OK? You have a Venmo or CashApp?
好的。大家想知道怎么给钱。所以一会儿，我们走去汤米的聊天室，你可以对两个聊天室谈谈这件事，好吗？你有Venmo或CashApp吗？
Yeah.
有的。
OK.
好的。
Sorry.
对不起。
We'll get you set up.
我们会帮你搞定的。
My phone's about to die.
我的手机快没电了。
Hang on, hang on, hang on, hang on, hang on, hang on, hang on. Check this out. USB-C or lightning?
等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。看看这个。USB-C还是Lightning接口？
C.
C口。
Here you go.
给你。
Whoa, you're both.
哇，你两种都有。
There you go. Breathe. Do me a favor and take some deep breaths.
给你。呼吸。帮我个忙，深呼吸几次。
Mike sees himself as a helper. He got into activism around mental health issues after a hospital staff, he says, medicated him against his will. He's been diagnosed with PTSD.
迈克把自己视为帮助者。他说他在医院员工违背他意愿给他用药后，开始投身于心理健康问题的维权。他被诊断出患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。
Severe Complex PTSD comes from a life of trauma. So ever since I was like-- I have borderline personality. Ever since I was a kid, I've been traumatized. I've been abused. I've been picked on. I've been beaten, so, my whole life. And I go become a Marine and learn to stand up for myself, stand up for other people. You stand up for the weak, for the vulnerable. So that kind of propelled me into-- use my abilities and my skills to help people.
严重的复合型创伤后应激障碍源于一生的创伤。所以自从我像——我有边缘性人格障碍。自从我还是个孩子，我就一直受到创伤。我被虐待。我被欺负。我被打，所以我的一生都在受苦。我去当了海军陆战队队员，学会了为自己挺身而出，为他人挺身而出。你要为弱者、为受害者挺身而出。所以那种使命感驱使我——利用我的能力和技能去帮助人们。
A lot of people I talked to out here had oddly similar stories. Tough childhood, and then some life-defining, very American trauma that seemed to explain what they were doing down here. The war in Afghanistan, the financial crisis, the COVID lockdowns, January 6th.
我在这里交谈的许多人都有极其相似的故事。艰苦的童年，然后是一些定义人生的、非常典型的美国式创伤，似乎解释了他们为什么会出现在这里。阿富汗战争、金融危机、新冠疫情封锁、1月6日事件。
And each of these people seemed to find an antidote of sorts to those events via the streaming thing, recording this real-life, live-action, political video game. Being one of the good guys. Finding a community of people not just online, but in real life, but in an online way. A little audience who cares about what you care about and thinks what you're doing is important.
而这些人中的每一个似乎都通过直播这件事找到了这些事件的某种解药，记录这个现实生活的真人版政治电子游戏。成为好人之一。找到一个不仅仅是网上，而且是在现实生活中以一种在线方式存在的社区。有一小群观众关心你所关心的，认为你正在做的事情很重要。
For example, like with Mike, he's not getting along with his wife right now. He talks about that openly with his chat. She doesn't want him here streaming. She thinks he could get himself into some kind of vigilante violence situation. Mike is like, that's not me. And the chat is supportive. They ask questions. They talk about their lives. Mike's reading the comments out loud.
举个例子，就像迈克，他和妻子的关系目前不太好。他会在聊天室里公开谈论这件事。她不希望他在这里直播。她认为他会让自己陷入某种私刑暴力的境地。迈克说，那不是我。聊天室里的人很支持。他们问问题。他们谈论自己的生活。迈克大声读着评论。
"I was spiraling in the drain. It took a big family push, but I got help. I'm still here. Still have some very rough times, but I'm still here." That's awesome, man.
“我曾经在深渊里打转。在家庭的大力推动下，我得到了帮助。我还在这里。虽然仍有一些非常艰难的时刻，但我还在这里。”那太棒了，伙计。
(INTERVIEWER) ZOE
采访者：佐伊
Some streamers are very committed to documenting, like Mike. Some people come here to argue with the other side. Some are in it for the thrill of it, like a streamer named Mo told me he used to be addicted to meth, but now he's addicted to streaming. Some people are trolls. They're here to rile the protesters up into doing something that makes them look dumb or violent.
有些直播者非常致力于记录，比如迈克。有些人来这里是为了与另一方争论。有些是为了刺激，比如一个叫莫的直播者告诉我他曾经对冰毒上瘾，但现在他对直播上瘾了。有些人是喷子。他们来这里是为了激怒示威者，让他们看起来很蠢或很暴力。
Something fascinating that happens, though, when you're watching those guys, is lots of times, they're trying to prove that the protesters are the cause of the violence, but in fact, when you look at the footage, often what the footage reveals is exactly the opposite. It shows clearly that some of the violence would not be happening at all if the streamers weren't there. Here's an example from the night that we were there.
不过，当你观看那些家伙时，有一件引人入胜的事情发生了：很多时候，他们试图证明示威者是暴力的始作俑者，但事实上，当你查看素材时，素材往往揭示的恰恰相反。它清楚地表明，如果不是直播者在场，其中一些暴力事件根本不会发生。这里有一个我们去的那晚的例子。
Before we got there, these guys Rhein and Cam were filming themselves, tried to come into this canopy tent the protesters set up on the sidewalk as a sort of home base. A protester in a black helmet with a red anarchist sticker on it steps in front of them.
在我们到达之前，这两个家伙，莱恩和卡姆，正在拍摄自己，试图进入示威者在人行道上设立的作为某种大本营的雨棚。一个戴着红色的无政府主义贴纸黑头盔的示威者走在他们面前。
Hey, guys.
嘿，伙计们。
No fascists allowed in the tent. No fascists allowed.
帐篷里不允许法西斯分子进入。不允许法西斯进入。
Good thing I'm not a fascist.
还好我不是法西斯。
A protester in a fuzzy skeleton suit glares at them. "I'm getting medical treatment," she says to the phones looming over her.
一个穿着模糊骷髅装的示威者盯着他们。“我正在接受医疗治疗，”她对那些笼罩在她头上的手机说。
What are you getting treated for, herpes?
你治的是什么，疱疹吗？
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
哇，哇，哇。
And then in a sort of, "I'll huff and I'll puff and I'll blow your house down" move, Rhein and some streamers just bust through the tent as a group, to make the point that this is a public sidewalk, which it is. They are correct. But a guy in shark pajamas is almost knocked to the ground. As everyone spills out of the tent all together, you hear the protesters cry, "assault!" And Ryan says he got maced and pours water on his face.
然后，以一种类似“我吹呀吹，把你的房子吹倒”的姿势，莱恩和一些直播者成群结队地冲进了帐篷，试图证明这是公共人行道，事实确实如此。他们是对的。但一个穿着鲨鱼睡衣的家伙差点被撞倒。当每个人都从帐篷里涌出来时，你听到示威者哭喊道：“袭击！”莱恩说他被喷了防狼喷雾，往脸上倒水。
Assault!
袭击！
[INDISTINCT YELLING]
[模糊的叫喊声]
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
哇，哇，哇。
Here we go.
开始了。
Later, Rhein took a leaf blower from the protesters' supplies and moved it down the street. I asked him about what he was doing. What's the idea behind what he's even doing?
后来，莱恩从示威者的补给品中拿走了一个吹叶机，并把它移到了街上。我问他为什么要这么做。他到底想干什么？
You took a leaf blower?
你拿了一个吹叶机？
Yeah, I grabbed a leaf blower.
是啊，我拿了一个吹叶机。
OK.
好的。
And I moved it 50 feet down here.
然后我把它往这边挪了50英尺。
OK, so you just moved it, you didn't take it.
好的，所以你只是移了它，你没有拿走它。
Oh, I just did it to piss them off.
噢，我只是为了惹恼他们。
Yeah.
是的。
Yes.
没错。
That's what I'm saying.
我就是这个意思。
Rhein's a former Trump campaign guy and a former college football player. He's big and broad. Rhein has a track record here. The Portland police have noted that he reported he'd been attacked by protesters. He was surrounded by more than 15 of them and then pepper sprayed while on the ground one time. And the police have also seen him, quote, "antagonizing the protesters until assaulted," end quote. His X bio reads, "right-wing provocateur."
莱恩是前特朗普竞选团队成员，也是前大学橄榄球运动员。他身材高大魁梧。莱恩在这里有前科。波特兰警方指出，他曾报告自己被示威者袭击。有一次他被15个以上的人包围，然后被摁在地上喷防狼喷雾。警方也见过他，“一直挑衅示威者直到被袭击”。他在X上的个人简介写着：“右翼挑衅者”。
For example, some guy goes, oh, F you fascist! I'm like, oh, seriously? I'll walk up in their face and say, what do you want? And then they'll push me and I'll push them right back, and they fall to the ground.
举个例子，有人说，去你的法西斯！我就说，噢，认真的吗？我会走到他们脸上说，你想干什么？然后他们会推我，我也会推回去，然后他们就会摔倒在地。
That's provocative.
那是挑衅。
Sure.
当然。
And that leads to violence.
而这会导致暴力。
That's one night out of an entire summer, though.
不过，这只是整个夏天里的一晚。
So you don't think-- even though you call yourself a provocateur, you don't think you're really provoking them?
所以你不认为——即使你自称挑衅者，你也不认为你真的在挑衅他们吗？
With my physical actions, no. But my presence, yes.
就我的肢体动作而言，不。但我的出现，是的。
OK.
好的。
Yeah.
是的。
And is the point of that in order to make them react so that you can prove your point that they are violent?
那么这样做是为了让他们做出反应，好让你证明他们是暴力的观点吗？
It's to prove my point that they think they own the city. And my point, I do it to take away their narrative that they can do whatever they want.
这是为了证明我的观点，那就是他们以为他们拥有这座城市。而我的观点是，我这样做是为了夺回他们的叙事权，即他们想做什么就做什么。
This is precisely, exactly how many of the streamers and right-wing influencers feel. That even if Trump is in office, there's a double standard when it comes to the left and enforcement. The January 6th protesters were cracked down on and these protesters are not. So yeah, they might get in a protester's face and taunt them or film them. If the protester responds with aggression, well, that's just revealing who they are. It's fair game.
这就是许多直播者和右翼网红确切的感受。即使特朗普在任，在左翼和执法问题上存在双重标准。1月6日的抗议者受到了镇压，而这些抗议者却没有。所以是的，他们可能会怼到示威者脸上嘲讽或拍摄他们。如果示威者以攻击性回应，好吧，那只是揭露了他们是谁。这是公平游戏。
I want to pivot for a moment to say something about the cops. The cops are a great focus of the streamers' ire. They think the cops are in league with the protesters. They call them Cop-tifa, say they don't arrest the protesters enough. The protesters would disagree. The night we were there, though, everyone agrees, was a big turning point. It seemed the cops were cracking down.
我想稍微转个话题谈谈警察。警察是直播者愤怒的焦点。他们认为警察与示威者勾结。他们称警察为“警察派反法西斯主义者”，说他们逮捕示威者不够多。示威者则会持不同意见。然而，我们去的那个晚上，大家都同意这是一个重大的转折点。似乎警察正在采取严厉措施。
In fact, hours before Suz and I showed up here, 30 of them had descended on the protesters' tent and demanded its removal. The tent had been cleared before, but not like this. This time, there was less warning than usual and there was just so many police. In general, people said there were a lot more police all of a sudden, patrolling everything and issuing citations. And what made this happen, the streamers will tell you, a lot of it comes down to this one video, of course.
事实上，在苏和我出现在这里之前的几个小时，30名警察涌向了示威者的帐篷，并要求将其拆除。帐篷之前也被清理过，但不是这样。这一次，警告比平时少，而且警察太多了。总的来说，人们说突然间警察多了很多，到处巡逻并开传票。促成这件事的原因，直播者会告诉你，当然很大程度上归功于这个视频。
From early October, a video from Rhein, actually, featuring the most known Fox ubiquitous guy down here, Nick Sortor. He got into a scuffle with protesters. He was filming them. One of them started yelling at him, and then pushed him with an umbrella.
来自十月初，一段实际上是莱恩拍摄的视频，主角是福克斯新闻在这里最出名的尼克·索托尔。他和示威者发生了冲突。他当时在拍他们。其中一个人开始对他大吼大叫，然后用雨伞推他。
I will fuck your ass up, punk. Get out of here.
我会把你搞得天翻地覆，混蛋。滚开。
Then a crowd formed and he got pushed into this hole.
然后人群聚集起来，他被推到了这个坑里。
[INDISTINCT YELLING]
[模糊的叫喊声]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's more like a huge dip in the ground covered in grass. It's called a bioswale. It's for rain runoff.
与其说是坑，不如说是地面上一个巨大的长满草的洼地。它被称为生物滞留池。是为了收集雨水径流的。
He fell into a swale.
他掉进了一个洼地。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Two of the protesters and Nick were arrested for disorderly conduct. Nick spent the night in jail. Donald Trump texted him, "We are behind you 100%." Basically, keep your head up, like he was Tupac. Nick ended up released and not charged with anything. Immediately afterward, the Department of Justice, the Civil Rights Division, opened an investigation into, quote, "viewpoint discrimination" by the Portland police.
两名示威者和尼克因扰乱治安被捕。尼克在监狱里过了一夜。唐纳德·特朗普给他发短信说：“我们100%支持你。”基本上就是说，昂起头来，就像他在对待图帕克一样。尼克最终获释，没有受到任何指控。此后不久，司法部民权司对波特兰警察局所谓的“观点歧视”展开了调查。
Nick himself has started the process to sue the police department for $10 million, alleging systemic bias against conservatives, saying the department was "riddled with Antifa." Six days after the arrest, Nick and the other influencers were at the White House doing that roundtable. Yes-anding the president's promise to send the National Guard into Portland to police this block, because the police were not. And that got a ton of coverage on right-wing media. And that's why the streamers think the cops are acting differently tonight.
尼克本人已经开始起诉警察局，索赔1000万美元，声称其对保守派存在系统性偏见，称该部门“被反法西斯主义者渗透”。被捕六天后，尼克和其他网红在白宫参加了那次圆桌会议。他们附和了总统派遣国民警卫队进入波特兰管辖这个街区的承诺，因为警察没在做。而这在右翼媒体上获得了大量的报道。这就是为什么直播者认为警察今晚的行为与众不同。
Some of them, including Mike, the vet from Idaho, think the cops are scared of all this exposure.
他们中的一些人，包括来自爱达荷州的退伍军人迈克，认为警察是被这种曝光吓到了。
All the streamers coming down here, just the pressure that's been built from it and Fox News talking about them, they have to enforce the law and it has to be equally. So it's brought-- it definitely, definitely change things.
所有来到这里的直播者，仅仅是因此产生的压力，还有福克斯新闻对他们的讨论，他们必须执法，而且必须是平等执法。所以它确实——它确实改变了事情。
But why take Mike's word for it? Guess who showed up for Patriots weekend. It's Nick Sortor, himself. He's right here.
但为什么要听迈克的话？猜猜谁出现在了“爱国周末”。正是尼克·索托尔本人。他就在这儿。
What do you think, Nick? Do you think that stuff like what happened to you changed what the police were doing?
你怎么看，尼克？你认为像发生在你身上的这类事改变了警察的行为吗？
I mean, it sort of brought the-- it brought nationwide attention to the issue. Obviously, my intent was to bring nationwide attention to the issue, but not in that manner.
我的意思是，它在某种程度上引起了——它引起了全国对这个问题的关注。显然，我的目的是引起全国对这个问题的关注，但不是以那种方式。
Not in the manner of getting arrested.
不是以被捕的方式。
Not in the manner of being arrested. But I was on Laura Ingraham's show, I guess, three hours before I was arrested. The fact that I had just done that hit and it was fresh, and then I was arrested on a Thursday night, and then that whole Friday was just nonstop coverage of the arrest. Ever since then, I mean, they've pretty much been talking about it in at least one segment of each show every night. So I mean, I've done probably six or seven prime-time Fox hits since then.
不是以被捕的方式。但我猜在被捕前三个小时，我还在劳拉·英格拉汉姆的节目上。事实上，我刚刚做了那个连线而且很新鲜，然后在周四晚上被捕，然后整个周五都在对逮捕进行不停的报道。从那时起，我的意思是，他们每晚在每个节目的至少一个片段中都在谈论它。所以我的意思是，在那之后我可能已经做了六七次福克斯黄金时段的连线。
Standing here on this block full of streamers, I just want to point out this is the dream, saturation coverage, with footage these guys filmed, stamped with their handles.
站在这里，在这满是直播者的街区，我只想指出，这就是梦想：饱和式覆盖，加上这些人拍摄的、盖着他们账号戳的素材。
Anyway, after all the attention Nick got for his arrest, including the Department of Justice investigation into the Portland police, it seemed to the streamers that the cops were policing the protesters more strictly, like clearing the tent and everything.
总之，在尼克因被捕而受到所有关注后，包括对波特兰警察局的司法部调查，直播者们认为警察对示威者的执法更加严格了，比如清理帐篷什么的。
So we asked the police, were the streamers right? Were they policing differently after Nick Sortor? And they responded, they were doing more enforcement, but for a different reason. Quote, "If there was any change, it was in the crowd's behavior. We began to see an influx of streamers, the people who want to monetize the situation."
所以我们问警察，直播者说对了吗？在尼克·索托尔事件之后，他们的执法是否不同？他们回应说，他们确实在加强执法，但原因是不同的。引述：“如果有什么变化，那就是人群行为的变化。我们开始看到大量直播者的涌入，那些想要将局势货币化的人。”
Still quoting the police here, they went on, "The increase in the number of live streamers and personalities in the area contributed to an environment where tension and confrontation escalated. Many of these individuals were creating content for audiences that reward intensity and conflict, which can sometimes amplify volatile situations." In other words, the live streamers made the protesters act up, and the police cracked down on both of them.
继续引用警察的话：“在该地区直播者和公众人物数量的增加，导致了一种紧张局势和对抗升级的环境。这些人中的许多人正在为奖励紧张和冲突的受众创造内容，这有时会放大不稳定的局势。”换句话说，直播者让示威者闹事，警察对双方都采取了严厉措施。
That is definitely not how the streamers interpreted things. On this night, certainly, they just thought they were winning.
这绝对不是直播者对事情的解读方式。至少在这一晚，他们只是认为自己赢了。
It's after midnight now. The streamers seem to be on a high. They've seen the cops clear the protesters' tent. The cops seem to be listening to them. They're filled with this "we're winning" adrenaline. They want to do something. So they start this march down the street towards this apartment. Something like 30-odd people marching, with their phones aloft, yelling someone's name. Chandler, Chandler.
现在是午夜过后。直播者似乎处于兴奋状态。他们看到警察清理了示威者的帐篷。警察似乎在听他们的话。他们充满了这种“我们赢了”的肾上腺素。他们想做点什么。所以他们开始沿着街道向那个公寓走去。大约30多个人走着，高举着手机，大喊着某人的名字：钱德勒，钱德勒。
[CROWD YELLING CHANDLER]
[人群高喊钱德勒]
They opened the door to this guy's apartment. It just opens, which is shocking to see and feels a little scary. Like, is someone going to get dragged out and beat up in some soccer hooligany way?
他们打开了这个家伙公寓的门。门就这么开了，这看起来很震惊，让人觉得有点可怕。就像，会不会有人被拖出来像足球流氓那样被暴打一顿？
Chandler!
钱德勒！
We want to have a discussion. Is anybody home? Chandler!
我们想进行讨论。有人在家吗？钱德勒！
[INDISTINCT YELLING]
[模糊的叫喊声]
I find myself next to Chad Caton, the guy in a bulletproof vest who was yelling about stolen valor before. We're just a few feet back from the apartment door. He's streaming as we're talking, which is always how it is.
我发现自己站在查德·卡顿旁边，就是之前那个大喊“窃取荣耀”的穿着防弹背心的家伙。我们距离公寓门只有几英尺。我们在谈话时他一直在直播，这总是他们的常态。
What's going on here?
这里发生了什么？
So Chandler has been operating the Antifa out of here. They've been running this neighborhood, and these patriots have had enough. They're taking back their streets. And this has been Chandler's-- this is where they have attacked patriots and ran in here. This is a safe house. And this is where Antifa hangs out here in Rose City.
所以钱德勒一直在这里操纵反法西斯主义者。他们一直在管理这个街区，而这些爱国者受够了。他们正在夺回他们的街道。这就是钱德勒的——这就是他们攻击爱国者并躲进去的地方。这是一个避难所。这就是反法西斯主义者在玫瑰城潜伏的地方。
A lot of this stuff turns out not to be actual fact, but more like Chad's interpretation of things, which others would strongly disagree with. But he is speaking the way most streamers and influencers would about Chandler's apartment-- that is, Antifa headquarters. Another streamer, Nick Shirley, runs up to Chad.
这些东西很多后来证明并非事实，更像是查德对事情的解读，其他人会强烈反对。但他讲话的方式和大多数直播者及网红谈论钱德勒公寓的方式一样——即反法西斯主义者总部。另一个直播者，尼克·雪莉，跑到查德身边。
What's going on? What have I missed?
发生什么了？我错过了什么？
Chad catches him and his viewers up with the not exactly true things that he told me.
查德向他和他的观众更新了那些他告诉我的并不完全属实的事情。
They're just letting Chandler know that the bullying is done and they're taking back their streets. Yeah, this is Rose City headquarters. It's a storefront because he's a trust fund baby, and this is where they have their furry parties and all that.
他们只是让钱德勒知道欺凌结束了，他们正在夺回街道。是的，这是玫瑰城总部。这是一家店面，因为他是个信托基金宝贝，这就是他们举行毛绒派对等等的地方。
Really?
真的吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
I'll just clarify, this is not a storefront. It's not the headquarters of Rose City Antifa. Chandler isn't a trust fund baby, and there don't seem to be any furry parties here, actually. But anyway--
我澄清一下，这不是店面。这不是玫瑰城反法西斯主义者的总部。钱德勒不是信托基金宝贝，其实这里似乎也没有什么毛绒派对。但不管怎样——
So this is the spot where Antifa, what, they just-- their home base down here, basically?
所以这是反法西斯主义者——他们的大本营，基本上？
Yeah, this is where they hide. This is the safe house, known as a safe house.
是的，这是他们躲藏的地方。这是避难所，被称为避难所。
Are you a fascist? Are you a fascist? No.
你是法西斯吗？你是法西斯吗？不。
At this point, Nick takes over from Chad, narrating for his live stream. He knows Chandler. A lot of the people watching his stream know Chandler. Any regulars who tune into the Portland scene down here know who he is.
此时，尼克接替了查德，为他的直播进行解说。他认识钱德勒。观看他直播的很多人都知道钱德勒。任何收听波特兰现场报道的常客都知道他是谁。
He's honestly, seems like a very-- he's a very normal person when you talk to him and have conversations. But he has been the most well-known person for being the head of Antifa here in this part of Portland, Oregon.
他老实说，看起来是一个非常——当你和他交谈时，他是一个非常正常的人。但他一直是波特兰这一部分最出名的反法西斯主义者头目。
So what are people doing outside his house right now?
所以人们现在在他家外面做什么？
Yeah, well, Antifa has kind of been defeated today, as they took down his encampment. So I think people want to see what Chandler had to say and if he was going to do anything about it.
是的，好吧，今天反法西斯主义者已经被击败了，因为他们拆除了他的营地。所以我认为人们想看看钱德勒有什么话说，以及他是否打算对此做点什么。
Chandler pokes his head out the door. He looks like a sleepy, tousled, blond, college kid who just rolled out of bed. He seems completely unfazed by the mass of shouting people and phones just outside his house. A few of his friends-- the protester in the fuzzy skeleton suit, another in a keffiyeh and goggles, a couple in all black-- are hovering around him.
钱德勒从门缝里探出头。他看起来像个睡眼惺忪、头发蓬乱、金发的大学生，刚从床上爬起来。面对屋外的叫喊人群和手机，他似乎完全没有受到干扰。他的几个朋友——那个穿着模糊骷髅装的示威者，另一个戴着头巾和护目镜的，几个全黑装扮的——都在他周围徘徊。
Chandler stands in the middle of the open door and starts addressing the group of chanting, angry, excited, victorious people.
钱德勒站在敞开的门中央，开始对这群高喊着、愤怒的、兴奋的、胜利的人群发表讲话。
It is entirely to the advantage of the powerful to have us, the working class, blame the powerless. Does that make sense?
让作为工人阶级的我们去责怪无权无势的人，这完全符合强权者的利益。这有道理吗？
No.
没有。
It is also very surprising to me to hear this Orson Welles-type voice come out of this young person's mouth.
听到这个年轻人嘴里发出奥逊·威尔斯式的声音，我也感到非常惊讶。
It is entirely to the advantage of the ruling class to convince you to blame the powerless, to blame the immigrants, to blame the left, to blame the right, to blame the rural farmers, to blame the liberals in the city, to blame the conservatives, right?
让你们去责怪无权无势的人，去责怪移民，去责怪左派，去责怪右派，去责怪农村农民，去责怪城市里的自由派，去责怪保守派，这完全符合统治阶级的利益，对吧？
He's ringed by streamers and phones, some of whom are just filming without comment, but a lot of whom are yelling at each other and teasing him. Because of the way Chandler talks, the whole thing feels just of another era, as though he's on a literal soapbox and people in bowler hats are on a cobblestone street, booing and throwing tomatoes at him. But it's just phones bobbing everywhere, and people narrating and arguing while he's talking.
他被直播者和手机包围着，其中一些人只是在拍摄而不加评论，但许多人却在互相叫喊并嘲讽他。因为钱德勒讲话的方式，整件事感觉像是另一个时代的产物，仿佛他站在真正的肥皂箱上，而戴着圆顶礼帽的人们在鹅卵石街道上对他嘘声并扔西红柿。但现场到处都是晃动的手机，人们在解说和争论，而他正在说话。
So when your SNAP benefits run out soon, when you go hungry, remember, it is the powerful. It is not the poor. It is the Democrats. It is the Republicans. It is the ruling class. It is the rich. It is the people who determine what our economy does. Does that make sense? They own our industry. They own our fucking housing. They own the hours of your fucking life.
所以当你的食品券补助快用完时，当你挨饿时，记住，是掌权者造成的。不是穷人。是民主党人。是共和党人。是统治阶级。是富人。是那些决定我们经济走向的人。这有道理吗？他们拥有我们的工业。他们拥有我们的操蛋住房。他们拥有你操蛋生命里的分分秒秒。
Thank you, Chandler.
谢谢你，钱德勒。
There is no left and right. There is only rich and poor. There is only powerful and powerless. You are among the powerless. We are among the powerless.
没有左派和右派。只有富人和穷人。只有有权有势和无权无势。你属于无权无势的那一边。我们也属于无权无势的那一边。
People are starting to get restless, unsure what to do next since this Chandler catharsis seems to be getting old.
人们开始变得不安，不确定接下来要做什么，因为这种钱德勒式的宣泄似乎已经过时了。
Chandler is still harboring terrorists after trying to gobble our knobs all night last night.
钱德勒还在窝藏恐怖分子，昨晚整晚都在试图玩弄我们。
Eventually, people do start wandering away from Chandler's house. Karlyn is giddy.
最终，人们确实开始离开钱德勒的房子。卡琳欣喜若狂。
Is it fun, though?
好玩吗？
Yeah, it's a ton of fun. Aren't you having fun? Wasn't that fun? [LAUGHS]
是的，太好玩了。你不觉得好玩吗？刚才不好玩吗？[笑]
Fun is not the word, but I'm looking for something to happen, and it was happening.
好玩不是那个词，但我一直在期待发生点什么，而它确实发生了。
Yeah, it's an adrenaline rush. It's like this isn't-- this doesn't happen every day, right?
是的，这是一种肾上腺素冲动。这就像——这不是每天都会发生的，对吧？
Yeah. But it does seem like you guys are making it happen every day.
是的。但看起来你们这些人每天都在让它发生。
Actually, it does happen every day.
其实，它每天都会发生。
It seems like people are making it happen every day.
看起来是人们每天都在让它发生。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
I give my business card to the guy who's famous for dressing as a frog at these protests. He was acting as a bouncer.
我把我的一张名片给了那个在抗议活动中以装扮成青蛙而出名的家伙。他当时充当保镖。
Can you just give this to him?
你能帮我给他吗？
The scene at Chandler's ends with a bunch of streamers taking group photos of themselves simultaneously with their phones.
在钱德勒家的场景以一群直播者同时用手机给自己拍合影结束。
Good job, boys and girls. You are all good kids.
干得好，男孩女孩们。你们都是好孩子。
Oh, my god.
天哪。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's like 30 people. Then some of them bring their phones close and bid fond farewells to their viewers online.
大约有30个人。然后他们中的一些人把手机凑近，向线上的观众深情告别。
I'll see you guys tomorrow. I love you guys. We won tonight, baby. We won. We're doing it right now. So I'm going to help. I love you guys. I'll make a post when I get home.
明天见。我爱你们。我们今晚赢了，宝贝。我们赢了。我们现在正在做。所以我去帮忙。我爱你们。我到家后会发帖的。
All the world's a stage, and all the men and women merely players. You can't help feeling like this is so performative and absurd, that even the menacing moments are just part of a drama they invented to keep whoever's watching on social media entertained. It's cartoonish. It's over the top. And the search for red Antifa on this block can mean a random ICE protester in a frog costume. It could mean that person who hit a right-wing influencer with a flagpole and then ran away.
世界就是一个舞台，所有的男人和女人不过是演员。你忍不住觉得这太表演性且荒谬了，即使是那些威胁性的时刻，也只是他们编造的戏剧的一部分，目的是为了让社交媒体上的观众感到娱乐。这很卡通化。这太夸张了。在这个街区寻找红色的反法西斯主义者可能意味着一个穿着青蛙服的随机ICE抗议者。它可能意味着那个用旗杆打了右翼网红然后跑掉的人。
But here's what else the word Antifa now means in America, partly because of the story the streamers are telling about Portland. There's a great smooshing that's happening now. Protest means Antifa. Antifa means violence. And Antifa is rampant, organized, networked, well-funded, and belongs in the sizzle reel with the much more famous foreign terrorist groups that Americans all know. Remember DHS head Kristi Noem at the White House roundtable with the streamers.
但这就是“反法西斯主义者”这个词现在在美国的含义，部分是因为直播者讲述的关于波特兰的故事。现在发生了一种巨大的混淆。抗议意味着反法西斯主义者。反法西斯主义者意味着暴力。而反法西斯主义者猖獗、有组织、有网络、资金充足，属于那种美国人都知道的更著名的外国恐怖组织热场片。记得白宫圆桌会议上国土安全部部长克里斯蒂·诺姆对直播者说的话。
This network of Antifa is just as sophisticated as MS-13, as TDA, as ISIS, as Hezbollah, as Hamas, as all of them.
这个反法西斯主义者网络和MS-13、TDA、ISIS、真主党、哈马斯一样复杂，和他们是一丘之貉。
So let's go inside the Antifa safe house, see for ourselves, and talk to the head of Antifa, so-called. After the break, the frog guy gets us in.
所以，让我们进入反法西斯主义者的避难所，亲自看看，并与所谓的反法西斯主义者头目谈谈。中场休息后，那个青蛙男带我们进去。
Zoe Chace. Coming up, Chandler's apartment. Could you be any more excited? That's in a minute, Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
佐伊·蔡斯。接下来是钱德勒的公寓。你还能更兴奋吗？一分钟后，芝加哥公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, The Making Of. We're taking a look behind the scenes at the people who are creating a story about Portland that's fueling a national crackdown by the FBI, the Justice Department, Treasury, the IRS, DHS. We've arrived at Act Two of our program.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《幕后》。我们正在深入幕后，看看那些正在炮制关于波特兰故事的人，这些故事正在助长FBI、司法部、财政部、国税局和国土安全部的一场全国性镇压行动。我们已经来到了节目的第二幕。
Act two, Inside the Safe House. OK, so where we left off, our producers Zoe Chace and Suzanne Gaber were trying to actually meet the so-called leader of Antifa. We pick up our story a couple nights later, outside his door.
第二幕，进入避难所。好吧，回到上文，我们的制作人佐伊·蔡斯和苏珊娜·加伯正试图真正见到所谓的反法西斯主义者头目。我们将在几天后的深夜，在他门外继续我们的故事。
We've arrived.
我们到了。
Oh we're here.
噢，我们到了。
Yeah.
是的。
The Antifa safe house.
反法西斯主义者的避难所。
Are you ready to enter?
准备好进去了吗？
[KNOCKING]
[敲门声]
We're welcomed in, and the first thing we see is this sign that's posted right in front of the door.
我们被欢迎进去，我们看到的第一件事就是贴在门正前方的那张告示。
"Three cameras and the Second Amendment."
“三台摄像头和宪法第二修正案。”
That's a lie.
那是谎言。
OK, so what does it mean?
好的，那是什么意思？
It's supposed to imply that there are three cameras, and also that I have a gun, but I have neither of those things. There are no cameras in here and I don't have a gun.
它本意是暗示有三台摄像头，也意味着我有一把枪，但我两者都没有。这里没有摄像头，我也没有枪。
So why did you put it up?
那你为什么贴出来？
To dissuade people from walking in and, you know--
为了劝阻人们走进来，你知道的——
Yeah.
是的。
--doing weird, dumb stuff.
——做些奇怪、愚蠢的事情。
Just a prop. No real guns, like so much else around here. So Chandler's apartment, it both looks like a safe house for a socialist and a dude living alone in his 20s. Two chairs, one desk, kitchenette. He offered us tea in measuring cups. Two bookshelves. Science fiction. Dune, Hitchhiker's Guide, Fahrenheit 451, Orwell, Vonnegut. But also, the complete works of Rosa Luxemburg, The Rise and Fall of Swedish Social Democracy. Psychology books. Chandler said he'd been planning to do cognitive behavioral science before he dropped out of college.
只是个道具。没有真枪，就像这里的其他很多东西一样。所以钱德勒的公寓看起来既像是一个社会主义者的避难所，也是一个20多岁独居男子的住处。两把椅子，一张桌子，小厨房。他用量杯请我们喝茶。两个书架。科幻小说。《沙丘》、《银河系漫游指南》、《华氏451》、《奥威尔》、《冯内古特》。但也全套收藏了罗莎·卢森堡的作品、《瑞典社会民主主义的兴衰》。心理学书籍。钱德勒说他在退学前曾计划攻读认知行为科学。
My name is Chandler Patey. I'm a carpenter, and I guess I have an apartment that is right next to ICE, and I'm an activist and protester. And I can't call myself an organizer for this protest, but I do usually organize outside of this event, because there's no organization on this one. [CHUCKLES]
我叫钱德勒·佩蒂。我是一名木匠，我想我住的公寓就在ICE旁边，我是一名活动家和抗议者。我不能称自己为这次抗议的组织者，但我确实通常会在这次活动之外进行组织，因为这次活动根本没有组织。[笑声]
So are you the leader of Antifa?
那你就是反法西斯主义者的头目吗？
Unfortunately not. Or rather, fortunately not, because first of all, obviously, I mean, you know that doesn't make any sense. Antifa is not an organization. There are organizations that identify themselves as anti-fascist, right? But there are organizations that identify themselves as socialist or conservative, and they aren't the entirety of that thing. So it just doesn't make any sense to say that you are the leader of conservatism, or that you are the leader of socialism, because it's an ideology. You can't be the leader of an ideology. That doesn't make sense.
不幸的是不是。或者说，幸运的是不是，因为首先，显然，嗯，你知道那根本说不通。反法西斯主义者不是一个组织。确实有一些组织自认为是反法西斯主义的，对吧？但也有组织自认为是社会主义者或保守派的，他们并不代表那个事物的全部。所以说你是保守主义的头目，或者你是社会主义的头目，这根本说不通，因为这是一种意识形态。你不可能成为一种意识形态的头目。这没意义。
I think it's important to be as clear as I can about this question, what is Antifa? There are organizations with the word Antifa in their name. Steel City Antifascist League, Atlanta Antifascists. One is famously from Portland, Rose City Antifa. It has a website. It has a flag. But the idea that all these different Antifa groups or anarchist groups are connected with a funding stream and a leadership, there's no public evidence that's true.
我认为在关于“什么是反法西斯主义者”这个问题上，我需要尽可能讲清楚。确实有一些组织在名字里带有“反法西斯主义者”这个词。钢铁城反法西斯联盟、亚特兰大反法西斯组织。一个很出名的来自波特兰，玫瑰城反法西斯组织。它有网站。它有旗帜。但认为所有这些不同的反法西斯主义团体或无政府主义团体都与资金流和领导层相连，没有任何公开证据表明这是真的。
That was the conclusion of the FBI during the first Trump administration. Trump's former FBI director famously said there are violent, anarchist extremists who identify as Antifa in this country. But he said it was an ideology, not an organization that the FBI could target. Self-radicalized lone actors, he called them.
这也是特朗普第一任期内联邦调查局的结论。特朗普的前联邦调查局局长曾出名地表示，这个国家存在自认为是反法西斯主义者的暴力无政府主义极端分子。但他表示这是一种意识形态，而不是联邦调查局可以针对的组织。他称他们为“自我激进化的孤狼”。
The current Trump administration, the second one, has obviously gone in a very different direction. So in this environment, you probably wouldn't want to be publicly identified as Antifa or the leader of Antifa, right now.
当前的特朗普政府，也就是第二任期，显然走向了一个非常不同的方向。所以在这个环境下，你现在可能不会想被公开确认为反法西斯主义者或反法西斯主义者的头目，对吧？
So why are people calling you the leader of Antifa?
那你为什么会被人们称为反法西斯主义者的头目？
Because there's this idiot named Velly Ray who's a streamer. He's very dumb. And I tried really hard to be nice to him for a long time, but he is just-- he's just so malicious and stupid. He just makes stuff up to be sensational. And he'll just try and overdramatize the things that happened, and sometimes that would include vilifying us.
因为有个叫维利·雷的白痴，是个直播者。他很蠢。我试过很长一段时间努力对他好，但他只是——他只是太恶毒和愚蠢了。他只是为了耸人听闻而编造事实。他会试图过度渲染发生的事情，有时那会包括诋毁我们。
I asked Velly about this. And he said he's been filming Chandler for six and a half months, and he stands by his claim about him 100%.
我问了维利关于这件事。他说他已经跟踪拍摄钱德勒六个半月了，他100%坚持关于他的说法。
I'd say Velly Ray is like Chandler's Moriarty, his Lex Luthor, his Joker. Except Chandler has so many nemeses, it's sort of hard to pick. Anyway, here's Velly Ray's stream from a few weeks ago.
我会说维利·雷就像钱德勒的莫里亚蒂，他的莱克斯·卢瑟，他的小丑。除了钱德勒有太多的宿敌，很难选一个。总之，这是维利·雷几周前的直播。
I'm following Chandler.
我正在跟踪钱德勒。
[INDISTINCT CONVERSATION]
[模糊的谈话声]
Chandler, I love you! Chandler! Chandler, don't go! Chandler!
钱德勒，我爱你！钱德勒！钱德勒，别走！钱德勒！
Someone in Velly Ray's chat posted, "You're like Brando in Streetcar Named Desire right now."
维利·雷聊天室里有人发帖说：“你现在就像《欲望号街车》里的白兰度。”
Chandler! Chandler, you just walked in a full circle.
钱德勒！钱德勒，你刚刚兜了个大圈子。
Because I was trying to walk away from you.
因为我正试图避开你。
You just walked in a full circle.
你刚刚兜了个大圈子。
Initially, when Velly Ray came around, Chandler would do the thing that he does. He talked to him, speechifying about political corruption and capitalism, unbidden. And Chandler says, at some point, Velly just started calling him the leader of Antifa.
起初，当维利·雷出现时，钱德勒会做他擅长的事。他会和他交谈，不由自主地发表关于政治腐败和资本主义的演讲。钱德勒说，到了某个时刻，维利就开始叫他反法西斯主义者的头目。
He started it. And then other people started repeating it because it got them clicks, right? And then as that kept happening, and then they found out that I live right here in the so-called Antifa safe house, and then they came up with all sorts of weird fan fiction stories that got more clicks, if you just say "leader of Antifa" in them. So it didn't matter that it was me. They just wanted that word.
是他先开始的。然后其他人开始重复，因为它能带来点击量，对吧？随着这种情况持续发生，他们发现我住在这个所谓的“反法西斯主义者避难所”，然后他们编造了各种奇怪的同人小说，只要标题里带上“反法西斯主义者头目”，就能获得更多点击量。所以是不是我并不重要。他们只是想要那个词。
Well, you're a main character. They needed-- you are a main character in the story of the protest.
好吧，你是个主角。他们需要——你是抗议故事里的一个主角。
That is true. It is easier to give a face to something to get more clicks, right? Yeah.
那是真的。给事物一张脸以获得更多点击量更容易，对吧？是的。
This is going to sound facetious, but it's not. Was there anything actually flattering about that?
这听起来可能有点轻浮，但并非如此。对此有什么感到受宠若惊的地方吗？
A little bit. It was like a joke that my friends and I-- we all thought it was hilarious at first, and then we realized that, oh, that's actually not funny anymore. And so now I actually get mad at my friends or other protesters in general if they even joke about it anymore, because it's like, stop saying that. That's really, really annoying. It makes me look super conceited if that joke continues.
有一点点。起初这就像我和朋友们之间的一个笑话——我们都觉得这太搞笑了，然后我们意识到，噢，那其实一点也不好笑。所以现在，如果我的朋友或其他抗议者再开这种玩笑，我真的会生气，因为那是，别再说了。这太讨厌了。如果那个玩笑继续下去，这会让我看起来非常自负。
The other reason to get mad at this joke, of course, is that it seems it'd be dangerous to be called the leader of Antifa by people who have a direct line to the White House and the director of the FBI.
当然，对这个玩笑感到生气的另一个原因是，被那些可以直接通向白宫和联邦调查局局长的人称为“反法西斯主义者头目”，这似乎很危险。
I'm surprised the FBI hasn't been here already. Or have they?
我很惊讶FBI还没来过这里。或者他们来过？
I mean, they're at ICE sometimes. I mean, there are people who claim to be FBI at ICE sometimes. And I've been detained while the FBI was there. And then they talked to me and asked me, so how are you organized, and who's your leader? Is someone paying you? Which is all hilarious shit for the FBI to be asking. Are you that-- are you incompetent? Are you stupid? Are you pretending to be stupid or do you think that I'm stupid? Which is it?
我是说，他们有时会出现在ICE那边。我是说，确实有人声称是FBI的人有时在ICE。我有一次被扣留时FBI就在场。然后他们跟我谈话，问我：你们是怎么组织的，谁是你的头目？有人付钱给你吗？这对FBI来说全是搞笑的鬼话。你是那样的——你们无能吗？你们蠢吗？你们是在装蠢，还是觉得我蠢？到底是哪一个？
Think they're trying to get you to admit to being the leader of Antifa?
觉得他们是想诱导你承认是反法西斯主义者的头目？
Not me. They asked-- for a while, they would ask everybody those-- basically those same questions. It was just really funny because it's like, obviously, we're not being paid. What are you talking about? Can't you just like, look at all of our private information? And then two alleged FBI agents gave me a brief interview where I didn't really answer any of the questions and just asked them how they feel about capitalism and corporate oligarchy and things, and just disregarded everything they said. It was pretty funny.
不是对我。他们问——有一段时间，他们会问每个人这些问题。这真太搞笑了，因为显然，我们没被付钱。你在说什么？难道你们不能直接查看我们所有的私人信息吗？然后两个据称是联邦调查局特工的人给了我一个简短的采访，我没真正回答任何问题，只是问他们对资本主义和企业寡头之类的感觉如何，然后就无视了他们说的一切。这挺有趣的。
You're playing into what they think is Antifa, you know, when you go in there to an ICE facility and you're talking to DHS and you're talking about how we need to get rid of rich people?
当你在ICE设施里对国土安全部谈论我们需要摆脱富人时，你这是在配合他们对反法西斯主义者的设想，你知道吗？
I'd say get rid of is not accurate, though. Because I'm a Democratic socialist. I like democracy. What we need isn't to just go to the rich people with a small group of violent Antifa rebels and then kill them. That's dumb. That won't result in lasting change. What we need is to convince everyone to--
我会说“摆脱”这个词不准确。因为我是民主社会主义者。我喜欢民主。我们需要做的不是带着一小群暴力的反法西斯主义叛军去找富人然后杀掉他们。那很蠢。那不会带来持久的变革。我们需要的是说服每个人去——
This next piece of economic analysis from Chandler is going to play differently to you once I tell you what his father did for a living. So just listen a little closer than you maybe were going to, OK?
一旦我告诉你钱德勒的父亲是干什么的，这段关于经济的分析对你来说听起来会有所不同。所以听得比你可能打算听的再仔细一点，好吗？
Rich people hate us. They will do everything they can to consolidate power. They will destroy the United States economy and therefore the global economy, so that they can drive everybody out of business and then buy up fucking all of the shit that people need to sell for the lowest possible price and just keep consolidating power over and over and over.
富人恨我们。他们会尽其所能巩固权力。他们会摧毁美国经济，进而摧毁全球经济，这样他们就可以把每个人都赶出局，然后用最低的价格买下人们需要出售的操蛋所有东西，并一遍又一遍地巩固权力。
Now, Chandler was a kid during the financial crisis of 2008, and he saw a very particular side of it in his own house.
现在，钱德勒在2008年金融危机期间还是个孩子，他在自己家里看到了它非常具体的一面。
So my family was-- started off being kind of wealthy up until-- so my dad worked at AIG Merrill Lynch.
所以我的家庭——起初挺有钱的，直到——我爸爸在AIG美林工作。
Oh!
噢！
That "oh" is the sound of someone thinking, oh, your dad was in the business of mortgage-backed securities that crashed the economy 17 years ago, when you were at a young and impressionable adolescent age. And now you're a committed socialist. Oh.
那个“噢”声是一个人的反应，意思是，噢，你爸爸在从事那个17年前摧毁经济的抵押贷款支持证券业务，当时你还是个年轻、易受影响的青春期少年。现在你是个坚定的社会主义者。噢。
So and then was a higher up, like a marketing director or some shit like that. And so we had a pretty big house that they built and designed themselves, because my grandpa was a structural engineer. My grandma is like a designer-- or an interior designer or something. My mom also has a degree in interior design or something. And so they-- pretty wealthy. Not super rich, but pretty wealthy.
所以后来是高层，营销总监什么的。所以我们有一栋很大的房子，是他们自己建造和设计的，因为我爷爷是结构工程师。我奶奶是个室内设计师什么的。我妈妈也有室内设计学位什么的。所以他们——挺有钱的。不是超级有钱，但挺有钱的。
But I don't know if you know, but AIG Merrill Lynch was one of the parties mainly responsible for the 2008 financial crisis. So when that happened, my dad lost everything and then went crazy and became a crippling alcoholic. And then I just didn't really see him very much ever again, which was fine, because I never really saw him very much to begin with. And he was kind of weird.
但我不知道你是否知道，AIG美林是导致2008年金融危机的主要当事人之一。所以当那件事发生时，我爸爸失去了一切，然后疯了，变成了严重的酗酒者。然后我就没再见过他多少次了，这倒无所谓，因为我本来就没怎么见过他。而且他有点怪。
I'm sorry.
我很抱歉。
Oh, it's fine.
噢，没关系。
Just to say, Chandler denies his economic analysis comes from his personal experience. He says it comes from observations about history. Fair enough, nonetheless. Chandler does not like to talk about his family much. He says he doesn't really keep in touch with them. He grew up Mormon, just outside Portland. His dad died earlier this year. He has found a family of sorts here at the ICE facility. Sorry if that's corny to say.
只是说，钱德勒否认他的经济分析源于个人经历。他说这是源于对历史的观察。说得有理，尽管如此。钱德勒不太喜欢谈论他的家庭。他说他并没有真正和他们保持联系。他在波特兰郊外长大，是个摩门教徒。他爸爸今年早些时候去世了。他在ICE设施这里找到了某种家庭。如果这听起来很陈词滥调的话，我很抱歉。
While we were there for a few hours, people stopped by and changed their clothes, used the bathroom. Someone gave him $10 for the water bill. A big wagon of medical supplies was sitting in the middle of the furniture-less living room. People had dragged it here after the camp was taken down by the cops. Some helped themselves to beef soup Chandler had on the stove. Not the vegan, of course, who called it flesh soup.
当我们呆了几个小时期间，人们进来换衣服，使用洗手间。有人给了他10美元交水费。一辆装满医疗用品的大车放在没有任何家具的客厅中间。在帐篷被警察拆除后，人们把它拖到了这里。一些人吃着钱德勒在炉子上炖的牛肉汤。当然，不是那个称之为“肉汤”的纯素食主义者吃的。
Chandler found a partner, a romantic partner down here at the protest. His first significant romantic partner ever, he says. They came by for a second. In any case, Chandler has a sign up on his bedroom door that says, "Don't go in my room. That's fucking weird." Implying that enough people came by and tried to go in his room that he had to put a sign up. Also, Chandler is autistic. He calls himself very, very autistic.
钱德勒在抗议活动中找到了一个伴侣，一个浪漫的伴侣。他说这是他有史以来第一个重要的浪漫伴侣。他们过来看了一会儿。总之，钱德勒在他卧室门上贴了个牌子，上面写着：“别进我的房间。那太他妈奇怪了。”这意味着之前有足够多的人进来并试图进他的房间，他才不得不贴个牌子。另外，钱德勒是自闭症患者。他称自己是非常、非常自闭。
And something that he attributes to his autism is his ability to talk and talk and talk very calmly to whomever is talking to him, however they're talking to him, even if, in my opinion, it very much makes him look like the leader of Antifa. Like our night with the streamers, when he gave that press conference of sorts, standing in his doorway.
他把这种能力归功于他的自闭症，那就是无论对方怎么跟他说，他都能非常冷静地与对方滔滔不绝地交谈，即使在我看来，这让他看起来非常像反法西斯主义者的头目。就像我们和直播者在一起的那个晚上，当他站在门口举行某种新闻发布会时。
I mean, you coming out was this incredible catharsis. And they were talking to us like this was spiking the football. It was a victory lap. The camp was down and now they were teasing, bullying, yelling at the head of Antifa at the Antifa safe house, wildly outnumbering him, and making fun of him and his friends. And why would you give them that content?
我的意思是，你出来真是个令人难以置信的宣泄。他们谈论我们就像在把球扣进地里。这是一场胜利之旅。营地拆了，现在他们正在戏弄、欺负、对避难所里的反法西斯主义者头目叫喊，人数上远远超过他，还取笑他和他的朋友。你为什么要给他们那种素材？
The content that I'm giving them is good for me.
我给他们的内容对我来说是好的。
Why?
为什么？
Because no matter how many people I've failed to convince, it is almost guaranteed that there is at least some people in their audience who responded positively to what I said.
因为无论我没能说服多少人，几乎可以肯定的是，他们的观众中至少有一些人会对我说的话做出积极回应。
How do you figure?
你怎么看出来的？
Because I have seen it. I go to their comment sections. I look at their comment sections. Fucking especially on Velly Ray's videos. There were so many of his fucking viewers that actually were on my side.
因为我亲眼看到了。我去了他们的评论区。我看了他们的评论区。特别是在维利·雷的视频下面。有那么多他的观众其实站在我这一边。
So you really think that the commenters on the live streams are turning into Democratic Socialists some of them?
所以你真的认为直播间的评论者中，有些人正在转变成民主社会主义者？
No, no, no. That would be crazy. I would love that, but no. I can only convince them on one point at a time. And--
不，不，不。那太疯狂了。我乐见其成，但没有。我一次只能说服他们一点。然后——
Chandler isn't always so above it all. He admits he takes the bait sometimes and gets aggressive, physically aggressive, which of course gives the streamers exactly what they're looking for, which is footage of the violent Antifa. He pulled up a video of a fight he definitely participated in with that provocateur guy Rhein we talked about earlier, and someone else called Right Side Rebel, who has long, swishy, blonde hair.
钱德勒并不总是那么超然。他承认他有时会上钩并变得好斗，身体上的好斗，这当然给了直播者他们想要的东西，即暴力的反法西斯主义者的画面。他调出了一段视频，内容是他确实参与了我们之前提到的那个挑衅者莱恩的打斗，还有另一个叫“右侧叛逆”的人，长着长长的、晃动的金发。
And then I get pulled off of Right Side Rebel. Everybody pulls me off of Right Side Rebel. And then I restrain Right Side Rebel again, and then it fizzles out after that. And--
然后我被从“右侧叛逆”身上拉开了。每个人都把我从“右侧叛逆”身上拉开。然后我再次控制住“右侧叛逆”，之后就没下文了。然后——
But don't you think-- I mean, this is exactly what people are out there to stream. This is what they want to see.
但你不认为——我的意思是，这就是人们在外面直播的东西。这就是他们想看到的。
There was six more-- I don't know how many more fights that night. But yeah, afterwards, I went and I apologized to Right Side Rebel and we smoothed it over.
那晚还有六次——我不知道还有多少次打斗。但是的，事后，我去了并向“右侧叛逆”道歉，我们把它摆平了。
I was holding you back. I apologize if it seemed like I was--
我当时是在拉住你。如果看起来像我是在——我很抱歉。
(SUBJECT) RIGHT SIDE
右侧阵营
Actually, I apologize.
其实，我道歉。
(SUBJECT) RIGHT SIDE
右侧阵营
You guys just united the country. Oh, my god.
你们俩刚刚团结了国家。天哪。
I was just trying--
我只是在尝试——
So there was no reason for us to stay mad at each other. And then we were very friendly with each other and had another interview with Right Side Rebel afterwards, just and we're hugging and stuff, showing that we are friends now.
所以我们没理由继续生对方的气。然后我们互相非常友好，事后还和“右侧叛逆”进行了另一次采访，只是拥抱什么的，显示我们现在是朋友了。
Are you friends with Right Side Rebel?
你是“右侧叛逆”的朋友吗？
Friends is a strong word, but I was friendly, right?
“朋友”是个很重的词，但我当时很友好，对吧？
Just again, so this clip so easily could be on Fox, and maybe has been on Fox.
再次声明，这个视频片段太容易出现在福克斯新闻上了，也许确实已经在福克斯新闻上播出过。
Probably been on, yeah.
可能已经播过了，是的。
And is just exactly, exactly what the administration wants to see in order to carry out their policies.
这正好就是行政当局想要看到的，以便执行他们的政策。
I absolutely regret this a lot. I was just so angry at Rhein.
我非常后悔这件事。我当时只是对莱恩太生气了。
It's so small and intimate, really, what's happening here.
这里发生的事情真的是太小、太私密了。
Yeah. Yeah, we know all of these people. Well, most of them.
是的。是的，我们认识这里所有的人。好吧，大部分人。
And it's so small, it is really something that it travels up all the way to the White House.
而且它这么小，它竟然能一直传到白宫，这真的很了不起。
Right.
没错。
The point is, these people know each other. They're in the same cast. They perform the same play, night after night on the same small set. They're like the dancers in West Side Story, coming out, dancing together on a city block, then going home to their respective neighborhoods until the next night, when they're dancing, fighting in front of an audience again.
重点是，这些人互相认识。他们在同一个剧组里。他们每晚在同一个小布景上表演同一场戏。他们就像《西区故事》里的舞者，走出来，在街区上一起跳舞，然后回家回到各自的社区，直到第二天晚上，他们又会在观众面前边跳边打。
These conflicts, these pint-sized scraps on a street corner, are not the sort of thing that, in the past, our government has sent the most powerful military in the history of the world to resolve. They're not the sort of fights that have led to anyone being labeled a domestic terror group, a top national security priority. Maybe there is evidence out there that Antifa deserves that sort of treatment. But it's not in Portland. Though I love the smell of napalm in the morning, there's no war here.
这些冲突，街角这些微不足道的摩擦，不是过去我们的政府会派遣史上最强大的军队去解决的那种事情。它们也不是那种会导致任何人被贴上国内恐怖组织标签、列入最高国家安全优先事项的斗争。也许外界有证据表明反法西斯主义者值得那种对待。但那不在波特兰。虽然我喜欢清晨汽油弹的味道，但这儿没有战争。
Zoe Chace is a producer on our show. Suzanne Gaber helped her report this story. In the weeks since they were in Portland in October, things have actually quieted down in front of the ICE facility. Fewer people out on the street. Some of the streamers have moved on to other cities, and other issues.
佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制作人。苏珊娜·加伯协助她报道了这个故事。在她们十月份在波特兰后的几周里，ICE设施前的情况其实已经安静下来了。街上的人少了。一些直播者已经转战其他城市和其他议题。
Well, the program was produced today by Nadia Reiman and Suzanne Garber, was edited by Laura Starecheski, Nancy Updike, and me.
好了，今天的节目由娜迪亚·雷曼和苏珊娜·加伯制作，劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基、南希·厄普代克和我剪辑。
The people who put our show together include Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Ruthie Pettito, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Ryan Rumery, Ike Sriskandarajah, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor's David Kestenbaum, our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
参与制作我们节目的工作人员包括菲亚·本宁、迈克尔·科米特、鲁西·佩蒂托、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、莱恩·鲁梅里、艾克·斯里斯坎达拉贾、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特和朱莉·惠特克。我们的主编是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆，我们的执行编辑是埃曼努埃尔·贝里。
Special thanks today to Nick Podany, Conrad Wilson, Troy Brynelson, Lillian Mongeau Hughes, Faiza Patel and Phil Richard at KCRW.
今天特别感谢尼克·波达尼、康拉德·威尔逊、特洛伊·布林内尔森、莉莲·蒙戈-休斯、法伊扎·帕特尔和KCRW的菲尔·理查德。
I've said this before, and I'm saying it again right now. If you sign up as This American Life partner, you help us continue making the show. Plus, you get bonus episodes. The one that we just sent out a couple weeks ago and the one that we are about to send out I am so proud of. These are such good episodes. You also get to listen ad free, and you get an archive of greatest hits episodes conveniently right in your podcast feed. Join at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. The link is also in the show notes. Thanks this week to Life Partner Mike Seaton.
我以前说过，现在再次强调。如果你注册成为《美国生活》的合作伙伴，你就是在帮助我们继续制作这个节目。此外，你会获得额外的剧集。我们几周前刚刚发布的那一期，以及我们即将发布的下一期，我对此感到非常自豪。这些都是非常棒的剧集。你还可以免广告收听，并直接在你的播客订阅源中获得包含精华剧集的档案库。在thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners注册。链接也在节目备注中。感谢本周的合作伙伴迈克·西顿。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Hanging around with family for the holidays, he's been reading children's books to his nephews and nieces, and he realized something reading Curious George.
《美国生活》由公共广播交流平台PRX传送给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。由于假期里和家人待在一起，他一直在给他的侄子侄女读儿童书，读《好奇的乔治》时他意识到了什么。
The guy with the yellow hat right there is Antifa.
那个戴黄帽子的人就是反法西斯主义者。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。